>> ♪ ♪
>> Sean: JOINING US NOW WITH
REACTION OF THE UNASHAMED POD
CAST.
THIS BOOK IS OUT TODAY.
I COULD NOT PUT IT DOWN:
AMERICA'S SOUL BLOWING THE LID
OFF THE LIES THAT ARE DESTROYING
OUR COUNTRY."
THE PATRIARCH OF "DUCK DYNASTY"
WITH CHASE AND AL.
YOU HAVE NO FEAR WHICH MAKES YOU
THE OUTCAST.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Sean: WELL, I AM REALLY
WORRIED ABOUT THE COUNTRY.
>> SO ARE WE.
>> Sean: 2 YEARS ON THIS
PROGRAM, I HAVE AN ENSEMBLE
CAST -- I DON'T WANT TO TAKE
CREDIT.
WE HAVE BEEN DIGGING AND
DIGGING.
THIS RUSSIAN COLLUSION LIE AND
ATTEMPT TO RIG THE ELECTION AND
THE INVESTIGATION INTO THE
OPPONENT.
SPYING ON AMERICANS IS A CLEAR
AND PRESENT DANGER TO OUR FUTURE
AND YOUR BOOK CAPTURES IT.
>> WELL, I JUST TRIED TO WARN
THE COUNTRY I LOVE.
I AM TOLD TO LOVE GOD AND LOVE
MY NEIGHBOR.
THEREFORE --
>> Sean: DOES THAT MEAN LIBERAL
SPIN?
JUST KIDDING.
>> I LOVE EVERY ONE OF THEM.
YOU DON'T LIKE YOU EATING MEAT.
CALM DOWN.
>> Sean: I AM NOT GIVING UP MY
COWS.
>> I LOVE THEM EVEN IF THEY
DON'T SIT DOWN AND LISTEN.
THE SCARY PART THE LIBERAL LEFT,
BECAUSE THEY DID NOT THINK IT
WORTH WHILES APOSTLE PAUL DID TO
RETAIN THE KNOWLEDGE OF GOD, HE
GAVE HIM OVER TO DO WHAT OUGHT
NOT TO BE DONE.
THE LIST IS THIS LANGUAGE --
LONG.
THEY ARE FAITHLESS, AND
RUTHLESS.
I SAID THE FILTH OF THE AMERICAN
SOULS.
I MEANTIME THE EVIL ONE.
>> Sean: THIS IS A TRUE STORY.
I WAS AT YOUR PLACE.
I WATCHED "DUCK DYNASTY" AND
REMEMBER THE ALLIGATORS ON YOUR
PROPERTY.
YOU LIVED IN A TRAILER.
YOU WERE A RICH MAN AND YOU HAVE
A FILTHY SEAT YOU WON'T GET RID
OF IT.
>> [LAUGHING].
THAT'S TRUE.
>> Sean: I AM LIKE CHANGE THE
SEAT.
YOU WANTED TO TAKE ME IN THAT
ALLIGATOR PIT AND DUNK ME IN THE
SWAMP TO BAPTIZE ME.
>> YOU HAVE TO LEARN TO TRUST IN
THE LORD JESUS.
>> Sean: THERE WAS AN ARTICLE
ABOUT A CROCODILE EATING A
PASTOR BAPTIZING PEOPLE.
>> YOU WOULD HAVE MORE TROUBLE
WITH COTTONMOUTH.
PICK A JACUZZI AND WE WILL
BAPTIZE YOU.
GET RID OF THE OLD SEAN.
I ASKED THE PRESIDENT ABOUT.
HE SAID I WAS A SINFUL MAN AND
SO WAS I.
WHAT ABOUT YOU?
CAVUTO SAID YOU ARE TALKING TO
ME?
HE SAID IT'S GETTING HOT IN
HERE.
[LAUGHING].
>> Sean: I LEARNED A LONG TIME
AGO FROM A DEAR FRIEND OF MINE,
YOU DON'T CALL YOUR FRIENDS WHEN
THEY ARE HAPPY.
YOU CALL THEM WHEN THEY ARE IN
TROUBLE.
I CALLED YOU.
WILLIE WAS IN A TREE HUNTING.
GOOD GRIEF.
>> AND I ANSWERED.
>> Sean: YOU ANSWERED.
IT WAS 6 A.M. YOUR TIME IN
LOUISIANA AND YOU WERE DUCK
HUNTING.
HOW ARE YOU HOLDING UP?
HANG ON A SECOND.
QUACK, QUACK, QUACK, BOOM!
HE DOESN'T GIVE A RIP WHAT I
HAVE TO SAY.
YOU DIDN'T WANT TO TALK TO ME.
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT CALL?
>> YES, IT WAS BECAUSE WE WENT
PUBLIC WITH OUR FAITH.
WHEN YOU DO THAT YOU WILL BE
ATTACKED.
THAT'S WHY WE ARE DOING OUR POD
CAST NOW.
>> Sean: YOU SAY YOU ARE
SINNERS?
>> WE ARE BUT WE USE THAT TO
SHOW PEOPLE TO TRUST IN GOD.
WE ARE TRYING TO CHANGE THE
HUMAN HEART.
IN THE POLITICAL WORLD.
EVERYBODY IS UP IN ARMS.
EVERY TIME A SCHOOL SHOOTING
HAPPENS IT HURTS US.
WE GET IN THE SAME DEBATES ABOUT
GUNS.
WE USE COMMON SENSE.
WE ALL HAVE GUNS.
IT'S THE HUMAN HEART IS MY
POINT.
>> Sean: HIRE MILITARIES AND
COPS.
THAT'S THE END OF SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS.
>> TRAIN A COUPLE OF TEACHERS.
DON'T TELL ANYBODY WHO IT IS
LIKE THEY DO ON PLANES NOW.
THEN YOU DO THE GREATEST THING.
YOU TEACH ABOUT LOVE.
THAT'S A REQUIRED SUBJECT.
>> Sean: YOU CAN'T MENTION GOD
IN THE PUBLIC SCHOOL.
>> LOVE IS KIND AND LOVE IS
PATIENT.
>> Sean: GOD BLESS AND THANK YOU
FOR COMING.